i'm kind of thinking of doing a whole
like a rosa starter pack
but i would sell a kit where it's like
an eyelash set
a contour a highlight because i always
catch you staring
i swear ask anybody dude anybody will
tell you you're always staring at me
well hi adam it's nice to meet you over
the zoom
yeah yes it's super nice to meet you
i'm so excited to talk to you but i feel
like i i first want to kind of address
what's happening right now and i want to
ask how
you're feeling about what's going on in
the world
yeah um it's super crazy and kind of
overwhelming right now
um especially since like you know
there's just so much hate there's just a
um it's kind of hard to put it into
words how like
crazy things are right now um but you
know i'm just praying for
for the best and i'm waiting for the
good outcome to come out of this
kind of just you know um yeah
what you are a comedic light
like i have to call you uh what inspired
you first of all to get on to tick-tock
okay so i was um i had seen videos on
twitter kind of just like little videos
here and there of like different
creators and i was like wait where are
they coming from they weren't on twitter
and i would see their their tick tock
icons in the top left corner and like
bottom right
yeah so i was like okay let me get tech
talk let me see what it's all about
and so i got it and i was obsessed oh
thank you
i'm not even hungry low-key i mean you
built this rosa character who's so funny
and so legal how did she
come about was this something that you
did pre tick-tock was it because of
tick-tock kind of walked me through
so i'm from san antonio texas and i just
felt like it was something that
san antonio was so familiar with so when
i uploaded it i was just like oh like my
friends can watch it
a little laugh here and there not
knowing that she was all over the world
people related to her all over the world
but yeah my intentions were kind of just
like oh like
my neighbors can laugh my friends can
laugh people from high school can laugh
you know
are there more characters that you're
working on right now
um so i kind of wanted to build rosa's
entire family so like her mom
her sister her dad like just because i
feel like all of that
can like just feel so like relatable
that feeling you know
what i'm reading
from my mental health dad how long does
it take you to
prepare for a t for making a tick tock
from the physical transformation
to the creative like the verbal what
you're saying
so to to film like one text it probably
takes me about
no longer than an hour just because
getting ready the getting ready process
is so fast i literally just like slap on
some contour and highlight
but the kind of thing and the eyelashes
don't forget oh yeah the lashes
but the creativity side about it is kind
of just like me i kind of just think
like
what did i do or like what would i do
it's kind of like what i say whenever i
make
a video a fun fact i can't like
come up with the concept unless i have
the full makeup on
like if i'm like i can't just think like
oh don't do this like
i have to like sit there and like
observe and kind of think like what
would elsa do you know
make a way shut up sir
did you ever think that that
rosa would become this kind of like
tick-tock
icon that people would would love her as
much as they do
absolutely not i didn't expect any of
this
my whole life has now changed what is
the biggest change
in your your life right now getting
recognized
in public that's like even without the
makeup like people are like wait that's
rasa like
yeah but it's just so dope like before
my life was just so boring i
i kind of just like you know i was
living
super normal like working hip job
um and now like it's crazy like i i feel
like i can talk to so many people and
like
i just have like a lot to be grateful
for do you still have the job that you
had before this all happened
no you left yeah i was getting kind of
crazy there too like
people that i used to work with would be
like dude like i saw you here i saw you
there like
my friend wants to meet you like hey
like wait are you like it was just kind
of getting crazy what were you doing
before this
i was a customer service representative
for a bank
oh my gosh i kind of took a leap of
faith
quitting that job but i just had so much
like
so much confidence in what i was able to
do like making people happy and making
people smile
so i was just like i have to like if i
don't i'll regret it you sort of mention
that you want to like branch out and you
want to see rosa's like family members
where do you see
rosa going like could she make a cameo
in a music video a tv show
once things sort of get back to normal
what what does the future look like
so i did want to do like a tour just
because i feel like people wanted me to
say in person i did want to do like a
like a
like a statewide tour like a you know
um
[Music]
um maybe it's kind of just super risky
because like you know the whole
um cover 19 pandemic but yeah that's not
that's really one thing that i wanted to
do
especially for my friends because i feel
like they wanted me here in person
you have a lot of celebrity fans i've
noticed
who shocked you the most by like sliding
into your dms or telling you that
they're a fan of yours
i did get a follow from scizza she
followed me on instagram and i freaked
out
and then i believe hayley bieber follows
me on tick tock i was freaking out
whatever i had a gutting like filled
with comments like
haley bieber follows you on it's like i
was like and she's only following like
three people or like eight people and i
was like
you're like i know right
it was kind of crazy her her and justin
are super active on tick-tock
yeah could there be a way for you guys
to maybe
collaborate on something have you talked
to her at all
i haven't but i'm like wait that could
be a possibility huh
also james charles we saw that you uh
hung out with him he gave you a little
bit of a makeover
what about lashes huh um these are my
favorite pair that i wear all the time
those i need bigger yes
it was so good how how did that come
about first of all
it started off on x and then we kind of
transferred over to twitter
and he's my friend now where he's super
dope i love him so much
i love that are we gonna see more
collaborations from you guys in the
future are you talking about that
hopefully we have to kind of like plan
something out but
hopefully we have something in the
future yeah has he given you any advice
about how to navigate you know stardom
and everything that comes with it
he's been in the public eye for a while
now
he's definitely giving me advice about
more of the business aspect of
everything
kind of just like how to handle things
and like how to you know
deal with certain situations um but he's
super educated he's like one of the
smartest persons i know
um yeah i'm really thankful for that
what like what is he
what does he have to say i'm curious
he kind of just tells me like how to
handle things like when it comes to
you know opportunities you know stuff
like that he
he knows and he puts his time into like
more
like he really like cares about
obviously the creativity but like behind
everything else like
the business aspect of everything he
really has like the full his mind around
it and like that's super like
admirable because i feel like that's
like a lot to take in a lot a lot of
knowledge to like handle
so yeah when you think about the empire
that
he's really built what is the empire
like that you
are hoping to build like is there maybe
an eyelash line in the future
that would be iconic um i'm kind of
thinking of doing a whole like
rosa starter pack but i would sell a kit
where it's like an eyelash set a contour
a highlight and
yeah i like maybe
maybe even nails that would be like your
meals right now
yeah these are um well
show me i can't swim
what does it mean for you to be young
and successful in this
industry i mean you are only 21 you're
seeing so much success and it really
happened
pretty quickly for you yeah what does it
name
um it's kind of crazy because i'm
thinking what i would say
to my younger self like my 12 year old
self
if i were to able to like talk to them
and like let him know that everything
was going to be fine it's kind of just
like
it makes my heart warm cause like i
don't know how to explain it
things are just like so what i dreamt of
whenever i was that age
like i would dream of this life you know
and for it to be happening it's kind of
just like
i can't believe it's still it's super
emotional for me
just because like the my my situation
before all of this was kind of just like
super crazy and like
i was kind of dealing like with personal
stuff and it's just like this
took everything away like it like it
made me so happy
i literally can't explain how like it
changed my life
like a whole 180 you know i wasn't like
happy with myself i kind of just felt
like i wasn't going anywhere
um i was working the same job i just
felt like i was so young
and i was working a job that like
i felt trapped do you credit tick tock
with sort of like
helping you come out of that time in
your life or do you think that you did
the work
and then it was tick tock like how how
do you do it
that app kind of just let me express and
like i
was able to make and still i'm able to
make millions of people happy
through that app so i owe it to them
like
it's kind of like i you know i'm super
grateful for that
it's pride month yes which is amazing
yay pride
how how are you celebrating like are you
gonna do anything
and and what does this month really mean
or symbolize in your opinion
so this is actually the first year that
i am out
as a gay man um so it's super special to
me
i'm super excited it just this is like
like i said it's super special because
like
obviously the the significance behind it
and like the history and everything
it's just such a great month and like
i'm just i don't know i don't know how
to explain like my
like my whole happiness towards this
it's just like it's so great it's a
great feeling
and yeah i'm just i'm super excited i
don't have much plans but
i'm just gonna let you know my followers
know because i do have a large amount of
the lgbtq plus community following me
um so whatever i can do to make them
happy and like you know kind of just
live it with them
that's i'll be doing that
you